[Music]
hey everyone i'm abby sharp
welcome to abby's kitchen and a morning
in the life of a very busy mompreneur of
two i hope you brought your coffee
[Music]
now before we get started of course a
quick disclaimer that what you're about
to see and hear is in no way
shape or form a recommendation of what
you should be doing so of course
always speak to a healthcare provider
about your unique healthcare needs
also apologies in advance for the kind
of crappy quality footage
i wanted this video to be as authentic
as possible and i literally just woke
up that day and was like i think i'm
gonna just start filming on my phone and
today is going to be
a morning routine vlog and that's what i
did but i also knew that if i set up my
whole
camera tripod situation that my kid
would get like really grabby and hyper
and it would totally make me like lose
sight of that kind of genuine
authenticity so
sorry about that but at least you are
getting a
true authentic look at my morning yep
you read that right 4 a.m my day usually
starts with a early morning feed but
honestly
i would way rather wake up to this sweet
little kiddo
than to an obnoxious alarm clock so the
snuggles in bed are always
a really nice treat so then i quietly
brush my teeth and wash my face
trying not to wake my sleeping hubby i'm
currently using this reversal
rosacea face wash and cream i honestly
don't know if it's helping but i did
find that i got rosacea during this past
pregnancy and
nothing is making it go away so this was
like a 2
a.m facebook ad purchase that i made and
i'm not sure if it's helping yet
but i'm going to try to stick with it to
see it through
but leave me a comment below if you have
other really great options or ideas for
dealing with stubborn rosacea postpartum
then of course my contacts go in so that
i can see the world and my apologies
if this totally freaks you out and then
i take my b12 all my other supplements i
actually take before bed
but because i already struggle so much
with insomnia
i really don't want to be taking
anything that's even remotely energizing
or stimulating
too close to bedtime so i usually grab a
piece of fruit just for like a little
bit of a carb boost early in the morning
before i do a little bit of working out
and no i would never eat a banana on
camera i don't want to lose monetization
folks
and that would be far too suggestive to
be safe for work
let's be real so then i try to get in a
quickie workout and no this is not a
high intensity workout this is pretty
low impact so i'm not doing any high
intensity
cardio i'm really sticking to a lot of
glute work
like the band work and also some kind of
low intensity
core work to help with my diastasis
recti
aka my ripped up abs courtesy of baby o
i'm also admittedly kind of out of good
shows so feel free to leave me some good
ones below
so i'm watching the trashiest show of
life counting on
and don't touch me please i am totally
aware of the controversy with josh and
it is
horrible but there is something about
this
big family just like loving on each
other and living this like
simple carefree low stress life
that's kind of a bit of an escape for me
and then we try to sneak in
a little work so i'm going to do as much
as i possibly can before the kiddos
wake up and also finish the rest of my
water here
which i flavored with lemon today and no
there is no
kind of magical health benefits to
drinking lemon water it just tastes
better than regular water to me so it
encourages me to drink more
later i actually much prefer
limes to lemons in my water but i did
use all the limes that week to make dark
and stormies
so yeah priorities and then
we try to do a few chores so the dishes
go away
the dog gets fed and kids get up hungry
and all hell breaks loose
just just joking i am trying to get into
a bit of a groove here
so for breakfast i do try to eat with my
son to model
good eating behaviors so today we were
feeling a little bit like oatmeal
so in addition to the oatmeal we had
some peanut butter in there
some hemp hearts some frozen cherries
some banana i think
and then i picked out a few dino eggs
from a packet of
quaker dino egg oatmeal and i kind of
buried those in there as well so that's
my little hack to make oatmeal more fun
but also still relatively low in sugar
so he gets to have some fun digging for
the dino eggs
and i feel like there's a lot of
nutrition going into
every little dig and bite he also had
some leftover smoothie that i think had
some frozen kale in it some
frozen cherries banana some breast milk
a little bit of yogurt in there maybe
some hemp hearts
and then i had a slice of whole grain
toast with some natural
peanut butter and some homemade chia jam
next i got my groceries delivered so of
course i put all of those
away and i always try to wash everything
before i put it back in the fridge or
put it away so that way
it's like a really easy intuitive choice
when i need a really quick
fast snack and speaking of snacks after
a little play time with e
it's time for my baby oh to go to bed
for his nap
all right getting ready for o's nap time
i feel like my life is just snaps and
snacks
i wish i could say that i love nap time
but in all honesty
they're so short it feels like i spend
more time
kind of changing him and feeding him and
getting him down and up from the nap
then i actually get to enjoy the nap
time itself
i'm gonna have a super fast shower
because
that's what i do these days if i even
shower and i'm definitely not gonna wash
my hair because
i don't have time for that and it
doesn't look horrible
maybe i will get to answer an email
these are things that i can only hope
for
these are the things that dreams are
made of in parenthood okay so i think
this is as glam as it's going to get
today
a ponytail no makeup because mama don't
have time for that
just do less yes
now we coffee right now i'm kind of
obsessed with this barista blend from
so nice it's a soy milk but i honestly
switch up my milk choices
every few weeks to keep my life sexy and
wild
and of course now we get back to work
not for long
so if you ever wondered why moms joke
about never having hot coffee
this is why we love our microwave
coffee i got a fun idea why don't we
play a little drinking game where
everyone gets to have a shot
every time that abby breastfeeds i bet
you'd be pretty drunk by the end of this
video
yeah i would love a drink i would love
to join you but i won't so don't mom
shame me folks
i haven't even finished my damn coffee
yet
so that'll be my drink of choice this
morning you are thirsty too boy
on the topic of breastfeeding i have to
say this postpartum experience has been
night and day compared to with baby e
who i
exclusively pumped for but breastfeeding
has been
such a joy and i just feel like i've got
such a nice beautiful bond with him it's
so lovely
he loves me of course he loves me when i
when i go away for the day working and
he comes and i come home and he's
just so excited to feed and just like
get the smiles
oh while i'm just sitting here i thought
i would kind of explain to you why i
don't do a lot of these kinds of videos
and why i don't show
images and footage of my kids like a lot
of other
youtubers i chose this life i chose a
public life
everything you know is out there on
social media when it comes to
me but my children did not choose this
and maybe one day they will maybe
they'll want to be youtubers and i will
gladly help them get there if that is
their their goal in life
and that's their dream but until then i
want to respect
their privacy and let them build their
own online presence
and also i just want to protect their
their safety and their privacy
so this is kind of a an agreement that
my husband and i came to before we had
kids was that
i can continue doing what i do and i
love what i do and he respects that as
well
but we keep the kids out of it so that's
why you only see
hands and the occasional feet and maybe
hear a squawk or two all right
that is all and it's at this point that
we attempt some play time
this is usually around the time where i
get about a million emails coming in
um oh gets hella cranky and i realize
it's only
10 am so when all else fails
dance party
mama can't hit those notes anymore
now with e back from being outside and
oh awake in the bouncer it's time for a
little snack
recently e and i have been loving whole
wheat english muffins because
they're just the perfect size for making
small little snack size
sandwiches i totally wanted this to be
an omelette but i don't think i've ever
successfully flipped an omelet in my
entire
life or career anyways then i just
smashed up a little avocado
smeared that onto my english muffin
through on the eggy and
to that we've got a really quick easy
healthy delicious
sami snack after our quickie meal it was
time for oh to go down for another nap
and i attempted to read him a storybook
but let's just say he wasn't feeling it
no
we're tired crunch munch that noise
again whoever could it be
well folks there you go a little 4 a.m
morning routine
vlog for you i don't even think it was
noon by the time i actually finished
that video a lot of nothing got
accomplished that day
but it sounds like my day every day but
if you liked that vlog
definitely leave me a comment below for
other ideas that you'd like to see me do
vlogging style don't forget to give the
video a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
you